I can't stand he named toddler music but
am i impairing my two-year-olds
cognitive development by spinning
Zeppelin instead of the Wiggles as long
as you keep your kid from seeing the
houses of the holy cover art her brain
will be just fine there's exactly zero
evidence that one kind of music helps
cognitive development more than any
other plus the supposed benefits of
music come from learning to play an
instrument not just kicking back and
admiring John Bonham's drum solo in Moby
Dick I certainly agree that do the
monkey buy The Wiggles belongs right
next to the Barney and Elmo theme songs
on Volume one of Beelzebub Greatest Hits
but don't forget the first tenant of
parenthood it's not about you
toddler tunes sell because there are
simple lyrics and catchy melodies make
Rugrats boogie and sing and spark a
lifelong appreciation for music so if
your tyke digs the kitty pap more than
Physical Graffiti suck it up a little
Wiggles now may pain your ears but it
could mean a whole lot of love for the
better stuff down the line
I'm mr. know-it-all which means I
already know whether or not you are
interested in clicking on the subscribe
button you are
you